[Musique]
avec nous c'est le vins Charlebois
directeur du Laboratoire de sciences
analytique en agroalimentaire de
l'université d'alozim monsieur
Charlebois bonsoir bonsoir alors tout
d'abord qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui est
quels sont les éléments qui vous
permettent de faire ces prévisions
lequel facteur vous vous êtes servis
pour en arriver avec cette hausse de 5 à
7 % pour l'an prochain
bah en fait chaque campus
amène ses idées sa méthodologie on
utilise des centaines de milliers de
points de données dépendant du campus là
mais on utilise surtout l'apprentissage
machine l'intelligence artificielle pour
arriver à des prévisions et chaque
campus nous offre des prévisions
différentes alors ok il faut créer un
consensus entre 26 côté
on est arrivé à consensus qu'on a publié
aujourd'hui même mais vous savez
l'exercice est toujours intéressant
parce que parfois on croit pas certains
modèles parce qu'on trouve que les
chiffres sont exagérés ou pas alors on
tente d'arriver à des chiffres à des
prévisions qui disons
sont plausibles finalement oui parce que
on se rappelle l'an dernier vous vous
étiez fait reprocher jusqu'à un certain
point d'être alarmiste vous aviez prévu
des hausses de prix de 5 à 7% finalement
ça a grimpé beaucoup plus que ça dans
quelle mesure les prévisions que vous
faites aujourd'hui sont fiables ou
réellement prédictives monsieur
Charlebois parce que beaucoup de
facteurs qui entrent en ligne de compte
on est encore très à l'aise avec nos
prévisions de l'année dernière dans le
fond il est arrivé un peu ce qu'on avait
prévu il y a un an plus l'Ukraine
finalement c'est un peu ça qui s'est
passé le coefficient Ukraine a eu un
impact assez important partout dans le
monde d'ailleurs le Canada le deuxième
plus beau taux d'inflation alimentaire
au sein du G7 actuellement même le taux
d'inflation du moteur est plus bas que
la langue ou le Danemark deux
superpuissances en agroalimentaire donc
on
la performance canadienne est quand même
pas si mal mais ça dérange pas les gens
à Montréal ou ailleurs ils vont ils
voient qu'il y a un problème à
l'épicerie on paye plus cher pour ce qui
est 202 évidemment je trouve que l'année
était plus facile à analyser parce que
bon disons que les mesures sanitaires
sont derrière nous pour ce qui est de la
covid les choses se replacent avec les
denrées alimentaires les en fait le coup
dur qui a été créé par l'évasion de
l'Ukraine là et est un peu dernière nous
il y a des grains qui sont expédiés à
l'extérieur de de l'Ukraine actuellement
pour assurer la production pour l'an
prochain alors les choses se stabilisent
tranquillement pas vite mais on n'est
pas sorti du bois dans votre rapport
vous dites monsieur Charlebois que les
prix vont quand même augmenter mais
peut-être de manière plus prononcée au
début 2023 est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
vraiment un apaisement ou même une
stagnation des prix vers la fin 2023
c'est possible c'est possible
actuellement le taux d'inflation
alimentaire est supérieur autour
d'inflation générale ça fait 13 mois que
c'est comme ça donc on a passé
l'ensemble de l'année 2022 avec ce
scénario là nous on passe que tout ça va
être renversé durant l'année 2023 le
programmement au printemps ou à l'été et
c'est là que les choses vont tourner
en même temps on anticipe ralentissement
économique et lorsqu'on parle de
ralentissement économique bien sûr
il y a plus de jeunes sur le marché des
gens achètent pas nécessairement les
mêmes choses on va peut-être
trajet à la baisse on va acheter
d'autres marques moins chères par
exemple et ça ça va être on va voir que
les épicés vont s'adapter vont nous
offrir premièrement plus de rabais des
produits de rappel par exemple chose
qu'on n'a pas vu tellement le depuis
trois ans donc des changements de
comportement important et durables
monsieur charles-bois le couponnage et
même certains sautent des repas carré en
ce moment on est pris avec ça cette
réalité là pour encore plusieurs mois
l'inflation alimentaire est tellement
violente là qu'on incite les gens à
adopter de nouvelles habitudes on
retourne aux années 80 ça fait il y a 40
ans c'était un peu la même chose et à
l'époque on avait justement développé de
nouvelles habitudes moi je me souviens
lorsqu'on allait au magasin les
étiquettes rouges on achetait pas des
quatre roues on n'achetait pas parce que
c'était pas un spécial donc on avait
vraiment vu un nouveau comportement dans
les magasins puis c'est un peu la même
chose qui se passe actuellement vous
avez des moyens monsieur Charlebois
aujourd'hui devant un comité
agroalimentaire à Ottawa pour parler de
la hausse des prix on a parlé de la
cupidité des épiciers vous étiez aux
côtés des géants de l'alimentation
justement qu'est-ce qui est ressorti des
discussions aujourd'hui
moi j'ai vu un comité qui posait
énormément de questions à l'eau Blaze et
empire moi je pense que les mauvaises
personnes se sont présentées gaine
Weston est le président de l'aublage
Michael le président de empire les deux
étaient
donc j'étais un peu déçu je pense que
comme titre était déçu aussi parce que
c'est pas ça c'est pas une question
d'argent et de donner c'est vraiment une
question de confiance c'est ce qui
manque actuellement est-ce qu'elle était
branlée cette confiance envers les
épiciers en ce moment de courrier oui
mais c'est pas le salon de la faute des
épicés vous savez moi je pense que et ce
que j'ai expliqué au comité aujourd'hui
c'est que au Canada on a on a un Bureau
de la concurrence un chien de garde sans
dents il y a un manque d'autorité on
complète jamais les enquêtes qui a eu
des enquêtes sur la viande le saumon le
pain
il y a jamais de conclusion donc les
consommateurs se sentent ne se sentent
pas protégés par le régime actuel je
pense c'est ça qui est le problème
actuellement politique en ce moment et
ce dossier là n'est pas terminé merci
beaucoup monsieur Charlebois au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI